The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: A trilogy,
if you will, on hashing.
We did a lot of
cool hashing stuff.
In some sense, we already have
what we want with hashing.
Hashing with chaining, we can
do constant expected time,
I should say, constant
as long as-- yeah.
If we're doing insert,
delete, and exact search.
Is this key in there?
If so, return the item.
Otherwise, say no.
And we do that with
hashing with chaining.
Under the analysis we did was
with simple uniform hashing.
An alternative is to use
universal hashing, which
is not really in this class.
But if you find this weird,
then this is less weird.
And hashing with
chaining, the idea
was we had this giant universe
of all keys, could be actually
all integers.
So it's infinite.
But then what we actually
are storing in our structure
is some finite set of n keys.
Here, I'm labeling them
k1 through k4, n is four.
But in general, you don't
know what they're going to be.
We reduce that to
a table of size m
by this hash function
h-- stuff drawn in red.
And so here I have a
three way collision.
These three keys all
map to one, and so I
store a linked list
of k1, k4 and k2.
They're in no particular order.
That's the point
of that picture.
Here k3 happens to
map to its own slot.
And the other slots
are empty, so they just
have a null saying there's
an empty linked list there.
Total size of this
structure is n plus m.
There's m to store the table.
There's n to store the sum of
the lengths of all the lists
is going to be n.
And then we said the
expected chain length,
if everything's uniform,
then the probability
of a particular key going
to a particular slot is 1/m.
And if everything's
nice and independent
or if you use
universal hashing, you
can show that the total
expected chain length is n/m.
n independent trials,
each probability 1/m
of falling here.
And we call that
alpha, the load factor.
And we concluded that
the operation time
to do an insert, delete, or
search was order 1 plus alpha.
So that's n expectation.
So that was hashing
with chaining.
This is good news.
As long as alpha is a
constant, we get constant time.
And just for
recollection, today we're
not really going to be thinking
too much about what the hash
function is, but just
remember two of them I talked
about-- this one we actually
will use today, where you just
take the key and
take it module m.
That's one easy way of mapping
all integers into the space
zero through m minus 1.
That's called the
division method.
Multiplication
method is more fancy.
You multiply by
a random integer,
and then you look at the
middle of that multiplication.
And that's where lots
of copies of the key k
get mixed up together and that's
sort of the name of hashing.
And that's a better hash
function in the real world.
So that's hashing with chaining.
Cool?
Now, it seemed like
a complete picture,
but there's one crucial thing
that we're missing here.
Any suggestions?
If I went to go to implement
this data structure,
what don't I know how to do?
And one answer could
be the hash function,
but we're going to ignore that.
I know you know the answer.
Does anyone else
know the answer?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Grow the table.
PROFESSOR: Grow the table.
Yeah.
The question is,
what should m be?
OK, we have to create
a table size m,
and we put our keys into it.
We know we'd like m to
be about the same as n.
But the trouble
is we don't really
know n because
insertions come along,
and then we might have
to grow the table.
If n gets really
big relative to m,
we're in trouble because
this factor will go up
and it will be no
longer constant time.
The other hand, if we
set m to be really big,
we're also kind of wasteful.
The whole point
of this structure
was to avoid having one
slot for every possible key
because that was giant.
We want it to save space.
So we want m to be big enough
that our structure is fast,
but small enough that it's
not wasteful in space.
And so that's the
remaining question.
We want m to be theta n.
We want it to be omega n.
So we want it to be at
least some constant times n,
in order to make
alpha be a constant.
And we want it to be
big O of n in order
to make the space linear.
And the way we're going to
do this, as we suggested,
is to grow the table.
We're going to start with
m equals some constant.
Pick your favorite constant.
That's 20.
My favorite constant's 7.
Probably want it to be a power
of two, but what the hell?
And then we're going to grow
and shrink as necessary.
This is a pretty obvious idea.
The interesting part
is to get it to work.
And it's going to introduce
a whole new concept, which
is amortization.
So it's going to be cool.
Trust me.
Not only are we going to
solve this problem of how
to choose m, we're also going to
figure out how the Python data
structure called list, also
known as array, is implemented.
So it's the exactly
the same problem.
I'll get to that in a moment.
So for example, let's
say that we-- I said m
should be theta n.
Let's say we want m to be
at least n at all times.
So what happens, we
start with m equals 8.
And so, let's say we
start with an empty hash
table, an empty dictionary.
And then I insert eight things.
And then I go to
insert the ninth thing.
And I say, oh, now
m is bigger than n.
What should I do?
So this would be like at the
end of an insertion algorithm.
After I insert something and
say oh, if m is greater than n,
then I'm getting worried that m
is getting much bigger than n.
So I'd like to grow the table.
OK?
Let's take a little diversion
to what does grow a table mean.
So maybe I have
current size m and I'd
like to go to a
new size, m prime.
This would actually work if
you're growing or shrinking,
but m could be bigger
or smaller than m prime.
What should I do--
what do I need
to do in order to build
a new table of this size?
Easy warm up.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Allocate the memory
and then rehash [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Allocate the memory and rehash.
So we have all these keys.
They're stored with some
hash function in here,
in table size m.
I need to build an
entirely new table,
size m prime, and then I
need to rehash everything.
One way to think of this is
for each item in the old table,
insert into the
new table, T prime.
I think that's worth a cushion.
You got one?
You don't want to get hit.
It's fine.
We're not burning through
these questions fast enough,
so answer more questions.
OK.
So how much time does this take?
That's the main point
of this exercise.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Order n.
PROFESSOR: Order n.
Yeah, I think as long as
m and m prime are theta n,
this is order n.
In general, it's going to
be n plus m plus m prime,
but you're right.
Most of the time
that's-- I mean,
in the situation we're
going to construct,
this will be theta n.
But in general, there's this
issue that, for example,
to iterate over every
item in the table you
have to look at every slot.
And so you have to
pay order m just
to visit every slot, order n
to visit all those lists, m
prime just to build the
new table, size m prime.
Initialize it all to nil.
Good.
I guess another
main point here is
that we have to build
a new hash function.
Why do we need to build
a new hash function?
Because the hash function--
why did I call it f prime?
Calling it h prime.
The hash function is all about
mapping the universe of keys
to a table of size m.
So if m changes, we definitely
need a new hash function.
If you use the
old hash function,
you would just use the
beginning of the table.
If you add more slots down here,
you're not going to use them.
For every key you've
got to rehash it,
figure out where it goes.
I think I've drilled
that home enough times.
So the question becomes when we
see that our table is too big,
we need to make it bigger.
But how much bigger?
Suggestions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: 2x.
PROFESSOR: 2x.
Twice m.
Good suggestion.
Any other suggestions?
3x?
OK.
m prime equals 2 m is
the correct answer.
But for fun, or
for pain I guess,
let's think about the wrong
answer, which would be,
just make it one bigger.
That'll make m equal
to n again, so that
seems-- it's at least safe.
It will maintain my invariant
that m is at least n.
I get this wrong-- sorry,
that's the wrong way.
n is greater than m.
I want m to be greater
than or equal to n.
So if we just incremented
our table size,
then the question becomes, what
is the cost of n insertions?
So say we start
with an empty table
and it has size
eight or whatever,
some constant, and
we insert n times.
Then after eight insertions
when we insert we
have to rebuild
our entire table.
That takes linear time.
After we insert one
more, we have to rebuild.
That takes linear time.
And so the cost is going
to be something like,
after you get to 8, it's going
to be 1 plus 2 plus 3 plus 4.
So a triangular number.
Every time we insert, we
have to rebuild everything.
So this is quadratic,
this is bad.
Fortunately, if all we do
is double m, we're golden.
And this is sort
of the point of why
it's called table-- I call
it table resizing there.
Or to not give it
away, but this is
a technique called
table doubling.
And let's just think of
the cost of n insertions.
There's also deletions.
But if we just, again,
start with an empty table,
and we repeatedly
insert, then the cost
we get-- if we double each
time and we're inserting,
after we get to 8, we
insert, we double to 16.
Then we insert eight more
times, then we double to 32.
Then we insert 16 times,
then we double to 64.
All these numbers
are roughly the same.
They're within a factor
of two of each other.
Every time we're
rebuilding in linear time,
but we're only doing
it like log end times.
If we're going from one to
n, their log end growths--
log end doublings
that we're able to do.
So you might think,
oh, it's n log n.
But we don't want n log n.
That would be
binary search trees.
We want to do
better than n log n.
If you think about
the costs here,
the cost to rebuild the first
time is concepts, like 8.
And then the cost to
rebuild the second time
is 16, so twice that.
The cost to build
the next time is 64.
So these go up geometrically.
You've got to get from 1
to n with log end steps.
The natural way to
do it is by doubling,
and you can prove that
indeed this is the case.
So this is a geometric series.
Didn't mean to
cross it out there.
And so this is theta n.
Now, it's a little strange
to be talking about theta n.
This is a data
structure supposed
to be constant
time per operation.
This data structure is not
constant time per operation.
Even ignoring all
the hashing business,
all you're trying to
do is grow a table.
It takes more than constant
time for some operations.
Near the end, you have
to rebuild the last time,
you're restructuring
the entire table.
That take linear time
for one operation.
You might say that's bad.
But the comforting
thing is that there
are only a few operations,
log end of them,
that are really expensive.
The rest are all constant time.
You don't do anything.
You just add into the table.
So this is an idea
we call amortization.
Maybe I should write here--
we call this table doubling.
So the idea with amortization,
let me give you a definition.
Actually, I'm going to be
a little bit vague here
and just say-- T of n.
Let me see what it
says in my notes.
Yeah.
I say T of n.
So we're going to use
a concept of-- usually
we say running time is T of n.
And we started saying
the expected running time
is some T of n plus
alpha or whatever.
Now, we're going to be able to
say the amortized running time
is T of n, or the running
time is T of n amortized.
That's what this is saying.
And what that means
is that it's not
any statement about
the individual running
time of the operations.
It's saying if you do a whole
bunch of operations, k of them,
then the total running time
is, at most, k times T of n.
This is a way to
amortize, or to-- yeah,
amortize-- this is in the
economic sense of amortize,
I guess.
You spread out the high costs
so that's it's cheap on average
all the time.
It's kind of like-- normally,
we pay rent every month.
But you could think of
it instead as you're only
paying $50 a day or something
for your monthly rent.
It's maybe-- if you want
to smooth things out,
that would be a nice way
to think about paying rent,
or every second you're
paying a penny or something.
It's close, actually.
Little bit off, factor or two.
Anyway, so that's the idea.
So you can think
of-- this is kind
of like saying that the
running time of an operation
is T of n on average.
But put that in quotes.
We don't usually use
that terminology.
Maybe put a Tilda here.
Where the average is taken
over all the operations.
So this is something
that only makes
sense for data structures.
Data structures are things that
have lots of operations on them
over time.
And if you just-- instead of
counting individual operation
times and then adding them up,
if you add them up and then
divide by the number
of operations,
that's your amortized
running time.
So the point is,
in table doubling,
the amortized running
time is beta 1.
Because it's n in
total-- at this point
we've only analyzed insertions.
We haven't talked
about deletions.
So k inserts.
If we're just doing insertions,
take beta k time in total.
So this means constant
amortized per insert.
OK, it's a simple
idea, but a useful one
because typically-- unless
you're in like a real time
system-- you typically only
care about the overall running
time of your algorithm,
which might use a data
structure as a sub routine.
You don't care if
individual operations are
expensive as long as all the
operations together are cheap.
You're using hashing to
solve some other problem,
like counting duplicate
words in doc dist.
You just care about the running
time of counting duplicate
words.
You don't care about how long
each step of the for loop
takes, just the aggregate.
So this is good
most of the time.
And we've proved
it for insertions.
It's also true when
you have deletions.
You have k inserts and deletes.
They certainly
take order k time.
Actually, this is easy
to prove at this point
because we haven't
changed delete.
So, what delete does is
it just deletes something
from the table, leaves
the table the same size.
And so it actually
makes life better for us
because if it decreases m,
in order to make m big again,
you have to do more insertions
than you had to before.
And the only extra cost
we're thinking about here
is the growing, the rebuild
cost from inserting too big.
And so this is still true.
Deletions only help us.
If you have k total inserts and
deletes, then still be order k.
So still get constant amortized.
But this is not
totally satisfying
because of table
might get big again.
m might become
much larger than n.
For example, suppose
I do n inserts
and then I do n deletes.
So now I have an empty
table, n equals 0,
but m is going to be around
the original value of n,
or the maximum value
of n over time.
So we can fix that.
Suggestions on how to fix that?
This is a little more subtle.
There's two obvious answers.
One is correct and the
other is incorrect.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Good.
So option one is if the
table becomes half the size,
then shrink-- to half the size?
Sure.
OK.
That's on the right track.
Anyone see a problem with that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] when
you're going from like 8 to 9,
you can go from 8 to
9, 9 to 8, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Good.
So if you're sizing and say you
have eight items in your table,
you add a ninth item
and so you double to 16.
Then you delete that ninth
item, you're back to eight.
And then you say oh,
now m equals n/2,
so I'm going to shrink
to half the size.
And if I insert again--
delete, insert, delete,
insert-- I spend linear
time for every operation.
So that's the problem.
This is slow.
If we go from 2 to the
k to 2 to the k plus 1,
we go this way via-- oh
sorry, 2 to the k plus 1.
Then, I said it right,
insert to go to the right,
delete to go to the left.
Then we'll get linear
time for operation.
That is that.
So, how do we fix this?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Maybe m
equal m/3 or something?
PROFESSOR: M equals n over 3.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: And then still
leave it [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Good.
I'm going to do 4,
if you don't mind.
I'll keep it powers of 2.
Any number bigger
than 3 will work--
or any number bigger
than 2 will work here.
But it's kind of nice to
stick to powers of two.
Just for fun.
I mean, doesn't really
matter because, as you say,
we're still going to
shrink to half the size,
but we're only going to trigger
it when we are 3/4 empty.
We're only using a
quarter of the space.
Then, it turns
out you can afford
to shrink to half the
size because in order
to explode again, in order
to need to grow again,
you have to still insert
n over m-- m over 2 items.
Because it's half empty.
So when you're only
a quarter full,
you shrink to become a half
full because then to grow again
requires a lot of insertions.
I haven't proved anything
here, but it turns out
if you do this, the amortized
time becomes constant.
For k insertions and deletions,
arbitrary combination,
you'll maintain linear
size because of these two--
because you're
maintaining the invariant
that m is between n and 4n.
You maintain that invariant.
That's easy to check.
So you always have linear size.
And the amortized running
time becomes constant.
We don't really have time
to prove that in the class.
It's a little bit tricky.
Read the textbook if
you want to know it.
That's table doubling.
Questions?
All right.
Boring.
No.
It's cool because
not only can we
solve the hashing problem
of how do we set m in order
to keep alpha a constant, we
can also solve Python lists.
Python lists are also
known as resizable arrays.
You may have wondered
how they work.
Because they offer
random access,
we can go to the ith
item in constant time
and modify it or get the value.
We can add a new item at
the end in constant time.
That's append.
list.append.
And we can delete the last
item in constant time.
One version is list.pop.
It's also delete list,
square bracket minus 1.
You should know that
deleting the first item
is not constant time.
That takes linear
time because what
it does is it copies
all the values over.
Python lists are
implemented by arrays.
But how do you support
this dynamicness
where you can increase the
length and decrease the length,
and still keep linear space?
Well, you do table doubling.
And I don't know
whether Python uses
two or some other
constant, but any constant
will do, as long as the
deletion constant is
smaller than the
insertion constant.
And that's how they work.
So in fact, list.append
and list.pop
are constant amortized.
Before, we just
said for simplicity,
they're constant time
and for the most part
you can just think of
them as constant time.
But in reality, they
are constant amortized.
Now for fun, just in
case you're curious,
you can do all of this
stuff in constant worst case
time per operation.
May be a fun exercise.
Do you want to know how?
Yeah?
Rough idea is when you
realize that you're
getting kind of full, you
start building on the side
a new table of twice the size.
And every time you insert
into the actual table,
you move like five of the
items over to the new table,
or some constant-- it needs
to be a big enough constant.
So that by the time
you're full, you just
switch over immediately
to the other structure.
It's kind of cool.
It's very tricky to
actually get that to work.
But if you're in a
real time system,
you might care to know that.
For the most part, people
don't implement those things
because they're
complicated, but it
is possible to get rid
of all these amortized.
Cool.
Let's move onto the next topic,
which is more hashing related.
This was sort of
general data structures
in order to implement
hashing with chaining,
but didn't really care
about hashing per se.
We assumed here that we can
evaluate the hash function
in constant time, that we can
do insertion in constant time,
but that's the name
of the game here.
But otherwise, we
didn't really care--
as long as the rebuilding
was linear time,
this technique works.
Now we're going to look
at a new problem that
has lots of practical
applications.
I mentioned some
of these problems
in the last class, which
is string matching.
This is essentially the problem.
How many people have
used Grep in their life?
OK, most of you.
How many people have used
Find in a text editor?
OK, the rest of you.
And so this are the
same sorts of problems.
You want to search for
a pattern, which is just
going to be a substring
in some giant string which
is your document, your
file, if you will.
So state this formally--
given two strings, s and t,
you want to know does s
occur as a substring of t?
So for example, maybe
s is a string 6006
and t is your entire--
the mail that you've ever
received in your life or
your inbox, or something.
So t is big, typically,
and s is small.
It's what you type usually.
Maybe you're searching
for all email from Piazza,
so you put the Piazza
from string or whatever.
You're searching for
that in this giant thing
and you'd like to
do that quickly.
Another application, s is
what you type in Google.
t is the entire web.
That's what Google does.
It searches for the
string in the entire web.
I'm not joking.
OK?
Fine.
So we'd like to do that.
What's the obvious way
to search for a substring
in a giant string?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Check each
substring of that length.
PROFESSOR: Just check each
substring of the right length.
So it's got to be
the length of s.
And there's only a linear number
of them, so check each one.
Let's analyze that.
So a simple
algorithm-- actually,
just for fun, I have
pseudocode for it.
I have Python code for it.
Even more cool.
OK.
I don't know if you know
all these Python features,
but you should.
They're super cool.
This is string splicing.
So we're looking in t--
let me draw the picture.
Here we have s, here we have t.
Think of it as a big string.
We'd like to
compare s like that,
and then we'd like to compare
s shifted over one to see
whether all of the
characters match there.
And then shifted over
one more, and so on.
And so we're looking at a
substring of t from position
i the position i
plus the length of s,
not including the last one.
So that's of length
exactly, length of s.
This is s.
This is t.
And so each of these
looks like that pattern.
We compare s to t.
What this comparison
operation does
in Python is it checks
the first characters,
see if they're equal.
If they are, keep going
until they find a mismatch.
If there's no mismatch,
then you return true.
Otherwise, you return false.
And then we do this
roughly length of t times
because that's how many shifts
there are, except at the end
we run out of room.
We don't care if we
shift beyond the right
because that's clearly
not going to match.
And so it's actually length
of t minus like of s.
That's the number of iterations.
Hopefully I got all the
index arithmetic right.
And there's no plus
ones or minus ones.
I think this is correct.
We want to know whether
any of these match.
If so, the answer is yes, s
occurs as a substring of t.
Of course, in reality you want
to know not just do any match,
but show them to me,
things like that.
But you can change that.
Same amount of time.
So what's the running
time of this algorithm?
So my relevant things
are the length of s
and the length of t.
What's the running time?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
PROFESSOR: T by-- t
multiplied by s, yeah.
Exactly.
Technically, it's length of
s times length of t minus s.
But typically, this
is just s times t.
And it's always
at most s times t,
and it's usually the same thing
because s is usually smaller--
at least a constant
factor than t.
This is kind of slow.
If you're searching for a big
string, it's not so great.
I mean, certainly
you need s plus t.
You've got to look
at the strings.
But s times t is kind of--
it could be quadratic,
if you're searching for a really
long string in another string.
So what we'd like
to do today is use
hashing to get this
down to linear time.
So, ideas?
How could we do that?
Using hashing.
Subtle hint.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If we take something
into account [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so you want
to decompose your string
into words and use
the fact that there
are fewer words than characters.
You could probably get
something out of that,
and old search engines
used to do that.
But it's not
necessary, turns out.
And it will also depend on what
your average word length is.
We are, in the end, today, we're
not going to analyze it fully,
but we are going to
get an algorithm that
runs in this time guaranteed.
In expectation because
of a randomized-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: If we were to hash
[INAUDIBLE] size s, that would
[INAUDIBLE] and then we would
check the hash [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Good.
So the idea is to--
what we're looking
at is a rolling window
of t always of size s.
And at each time we want to
know, is it the same as s?
Now, if somehow-- it's
expensive to check
whether a string is
equal to a string.
There's no way
getting around that.
Well, there are ways, but
there isn't a way for just
given two strings.
But if somehow instead of
checking the strings we
could check a hash
function of the strings,
because strings are
big, potentially.
We don't know how big s is.
And so the universe
of strings of length s
is potentially very big.
It's expensive to
compare things.
If we could just hash it
down to some reasonable size,
to something that
fits in a word,
then we can compare whether
those two words are equal,
whether those two
hash values are equal,
whether there's a
collision in the table.
That would somehow-- that
would make things go faster.
We could do that in
constant time per operation.
How could we do that?
That's the tricky part, but
that is exactly the right idea.
So-- make some space.
I think I'm going to do
things a little out of order
from what I have in
my notes, and tell you
about something
called rolling hashes.
And then we'll see
how they're used.
So shelve that idea.
We're going to come back to it.
We need a data structure
to help us do this.
Because if we just compute the
hash function of this thing,
compare it to the hash
function of this thing,
and then compute the hash
function of the shifted value
of t and compare
it, we don't have
to recompute the hash of s.
That's going to be free
once you do it once.
But computing the
hash function of this
and then the hash
function of this
and the hash function
of this, usually
to compute each of
those hash function
would take length of s time.
And so we're not
saving any time.
Somehow, if we have the
hash function of this,
the first substring
of length s, we'd
like to very quickly
compute the hash function
of the next substring
in constant time.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You already
have, like, s minus 1
of the characters of the--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
If you look at this portion
of s and this portion of s,
they share s minus
1 of the characters.
Just one character different.
First one gets deleted,
last character gets added.
So here's what we want.
Given a hash value-- maybe
I should call this r.
It's not the hash function.
Give it a rolling hash value.
You might say, I'd like to be
able to append a character.
I should say, r
maintains a string.
There's some string,
let's call it x.
And what r.append
of c does is add
character c to the end of x.
And then we also
want an operation
which is-- you might call
it pop left in Python.
I'm going to call it skip.
Shorter.
Delete the first character of x.
And assuming it's c.
So we can do this
because over here,
what we want to do is
add this character, which
is like t of length of s.
And we want to
delete this character
from the front, which is t of 0.
Then we will get
the next strength.
And at all times, r--
what's the point of this r?
You can say r-- let's
say open paren, close
paren-- this will
give you a hash value
of the current strength.
So this is basically h of
x for some hash function
h, some reasonable
hash function.
If we could do this
and we could do
each of these operations
in constant time,
then we can do string matching.
Let me tell you how.
This is called the Karp-Rabin
string matching algorithm.
And if it's not clear
exactly what's allowed here,
you'll see it as we use it.
First thing I'd like to do is
compute the hash function of s.
I only need to do that
once, so I'll do it.
In this data structure, the
only thing you're allowed to do
is add characters.
Initially you have
an empty string.
And so for each character
in s I'll just append it,
and now rs gives me
a hash value of s.
OK?
Now, I'd like to get
started and compute
the hash function of the
first s characters of t.
So this would be t
up to length of s.
And I'm going to call
this thing rt, that's
my rolling hash for t.
And append those characters.
So now rs is a
rolling hash of s.
rt is a rolling hash of the
first s characters in t.
So I should check
whether they're equal.
If they're not,
shift over by one.
Add one character at the
end, delete character
from the beginning.
I'm going to have to
do this many times.
So I guess technically,
I need to check
whether these are equal first.
If they're equal, then we'll
talk about it in a moment.
The main thing I
need to do is this
for loop, which checks
all of the other.
And all I need to do is throw
away the first letter, which
I know is t of i
minus length of s.
And add the next letter,
which is going to be t of i.
And then after I do
that, I don't change hs
because that's fixed.
That's just-- or,
sorry, I switched from h
to-- in my notes I have h.
I've been switching to r,
so all those h's are r's.
Sorry about that.
So then if rs equals rt, then
potentially that substring of t
matches s.
But it's potentially
because we're hashing.
Things are only
true in expectation.
There's some
probability of failure.
Just because the hash function
of two strings comes out equal
doesn't mean the strings
themselves are equal,
because there are collisions.
Even distinct strings may map
to the same slot in the table.
So what we do in this
situation is check
whether s equals t-- I did
it slightly less conveniently
than before-- it's like i minus
length of s plus 1 to i plus 1.
Oh well.
It wasn't very
beautiful but it works.
So in this case, I'm going
to check it character
by character.
OK?
If they're equal,
then we found a match.
So it's kind of OK that I spent
all this time to check them.
In particular, if I'm just
looking for the first match--
like you're searching
through a text document,
you just care about the first
match-- then you're done.
So yeah, I spent order
s time to do this,
but if they're equal it's
sort of worth that effort.
I found the match.
If they're not
equal, we basically
hope or we will
engineer it so that this
happens with
probability at most 1/s.
If we can do that, then the
expected time here is constant.
So that would be good because
then, if skip and append
take constant time and this
sort of double checking
only takes constant expected
time-- except when we find
matches and then
we're OK with it--
then this overall thing
will take linear time.
In fact, the proper thing would
be this is you pay s plus t,
then you also pay-- for each
match that you want to report,
you pay length of s.
I'm not sure whether you
can get rid of that term.
But in particular, if you
just care about one match,
this is linear time.
It's pretty cool.
There's one remaining
question, which
is how do you build
this data structure?
Is the algorithm clear though?
I mean, I wrote it
out in gory detail
so you can really
see what's happening,
also because you need to
do it in your problem set
so I give you as much code
to work from as possible.
Question?
AUDIENCE: What is rs?
PROFESSOR: rs is going to
represent a hash value of s.
You could just say h of s.
But what I like to show
is that all you need
are these operations.
And so given a
data structure that
will compute a hash function,
given the append operation,
what I did up here was just
append every letter of s
into this thing, and
then rs open paren,
close paren gives me
the hash function of s.
AUDIENCE: You said you
can do r.append over here,
but then you said rs--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So there are two rolling hashes.
One's called rs and
one's called rt.
This was an ADT and I didn't
say it at the beginning-- line
one I say rs equals a new
rolling hash. rt equals
a new rolling hash.
Sorry, I should
bind my variables.
So I'm using two
of them because I
want to compare their
values, like this.
Other questions?
It's actually a pretty big idea.
This is an algorithm from the
'90s, so it's fairly recent.
And it's one of
the first examples
of really using randomization
in a super cool way, other
than just hashing
as a data structure.
All right.
So the remaining thing
to do is figure out
how to build this ADT.
What's the data
structure that implements
this, spending constant time
for each of these operations.
Now, to tell you
the truth, doing
it depends on which hashing
method you use, which hash
function you want to use.
I just erased the
multiplication method
because it's a pain to use
the multiplication method.
Though I'll bet you
could use it, actually.
That's an exercise
for you think about.
I'm going to use
the division method
because it's the
simplest hash function.
And it turns out, in this
setting it does work.
We're not going to
prove that this is true.
This is going to be
true in expectation.
Expected time.
But Karp and Rabin proved
that this running time
holds, even if you
just use a simple hash
function of the
division method where
m is chosen to be
a random prime.
Let's say about is big
as-- let's say at least as
big as length of s.
The bigger you make it,
the higher probability this
is going to be true.
But length of s will
give you this on average.
So we're not going to
talk about in this class
how to find a random
prime, but the algorithm
is choose a random number
of about the right size
and check whether it's prime.
If it's not, do it again.
And by the prime number
theorem, after log end trials
you will find a prime.
And we're not going
to talk about how
to check whether a number's
prime, but it can be done.
All right.
So we're basically done.
The point is to look at-- if
you look at an append operation
and you think about how
this hash function changes
when you add a single character.
Oh, I should tell you.
We're going to treat the string
x as a multi digit number.
This is the sort of
prehash function.
And the base is the
size of your alphabet.
So if you're using
Ascii, it's 256.
If you're using some unique
code, it might be larger.
But whatever the size of your
characters in your string,
then when I add a character,
this is like taking my number,
shifting it over by one,
and then adding a new value.
So how do I shift over by one?
I multiply by a.
So if I have some value,
some current hash value u,
it changes to u
times a-- or sorry,
this is the number
represented by the string.
I multiply by a and then
I add on the character.
Or, in Python you'd write
ord of the character.
That's the number associated
with that character.
That gives me the new string.
Very easy.
If I want to do is skip,
it's slightly more annoying.
But skip means just
annihilate this value.
And so it's like u goes to u
minus the character times a
to the power size of u minus 1.
I have to shift this character
over to that position
and then annihilated
it with a minus sign.
You could also do x or.
And when I do this, I
just think about how
the hash function is changing.
Everything is just modulo m.
So if I have some
hash value here, r,
I take r times a plus
ord of c and I just
do that computation
modulo m, and I'll
get the new hash value.
Do the same thing down here,
I'll get the new hash value.
So what r stores is
the current hash value.
And it stores a to the
power length of u or length
of x, whatever you
want to call it.
I guess that would
be a little better.
And then it can do these
in constant a number
of operations.
Just compute
everything modulo m,
one multiplication,
one addition.
You can do append and
skip, and then you
have the hash value instantly.
It's just stored.
And then you can
make all this work.